foreign
my hands are going to turn okay don't
have your hands like this your hands
turn this way
make sure you're doing that bone this
weapon is going to go
the hands are going straight but when I
turn my hands boom that's where you get
that Kessa angle from
not going to swinging it around your
head like this
top of your head
turn your hands that gives you the kiss
the angle so it should finish over here
on your Center Line not over here like
this
don't swing it through
stop
through that you have your body
your body is you're going to flex the
bow the bow
boom
they do not step like this
you're just doing your plan
oh right there hello
and then there's timing make sure that
it hits
on the back foot
so that the lead hip is driving
the weapon boom
no
then make sure you're not going
backwards
which is your weight back
and you put it all together
booms
foreign
taking out an assumption
right okay
[Music]
we'll do it embryonically like that okay
you're gonna stop
down
here
this part I want you to pay attention to
go a little slow this weapon comes here
cool
okay I am don't have my hand near where
his Joe would touch mine
my hand is over here
okay on my side of the joke not my elbow
on his side of the chip my side of the
chin that comes down where's my weight
only then end with it so
much
[Music]
okay
don't rudder
don't run around my foot that's your
grounding power foot
again
okay let's try embryonic embryonic
refers to a timing chain okay that's not
referred to
less complete or softer okay
you've trained hardness softness
intensity less intense according to your
partner got it or according to your
ability and process of information
but that's not what embryonic means okay
so
it's timing is different like for
example he comes around
and this is a that looks like a block to
me because it is it it's a block in the
embryonic version but there's no
blocking in Aikido okay so at this point
this now becomes a training Vector in
the embryonic phase
so this part would never happen in the
technique okay this is the embryonic
training so now you I use this Vector
all right so when I use this vector
I come down that line boom
this strike still has to go into his
hands and into his Center so not just
his hands
it has to go into his Center and to get
to his Center I want this to go
at least to parallel with the deck
no
here
parallel with the deck okay then comes
in the move
the embryonic
that's not me
get your weapon parallel with the deck
that's the minimum okay
you also though don't want it pointing
down
boom parallel the deck and then begin
[Applause]
okay let's try it together
all right so try to understand so I'm
going to give the opening but I'm going
to take that line on the center line
so I don't want to go here pass it
you see that okay
and I definitely don't want my tip out
of this fight because I'll never get it
there on time
so he's moving I go to the center line
engage the center line I sense the
weapon is coming around and I sense that
I got a nearer Target than his face
okay
so my path is here
away from the embryonic timing again
whether it's embryonic or it's the
actual technique has nothing to do with
intensity so you can do the actual
timing
less intense okay it depends on how much
I can process information meaning am I
doing the form correctly can I assess my
performance yes or no and then how much
value it can take that's that's the
intensity question not whether it's
embryonic or not okay
so I'm around this is dynamic
killing his Joe in in the stress
you'll see the threat right there
then you'll feel his threat so
that of Tosh has to go into his Center
cannot just stay out on his hands
you want his feet checked
[Music]
so that he stands still and provides the
necessary resistance for the atoshizuki
okay let's go
so your Keyhole assumes like all this
kind of understanding of the weapon
fighting okay so uh for example he goes
this is this is this is not a weapon
fight
I I'm here passive I sit here like this
well now I'm blocking okay and I would
just hit that thing as hard as I could
and then come in with my follow-ups
okay
it's not Aikido either because you block
it
this passivity too is
okay so for example let's just take a
basic keyhorn of kihon Wasa of ikeo okay
so the same thing I don't sit here and
then do you go from there
there is a meeting we meet I met and we
go right into the technique right
there's a connection that is establish
that connection first starts
immaterially
got it and it'll continue from there so
when I go here it's there's no
connection I wrote connection to do this
and then you'll have a material
connection this is not correct
instead it's an immaterial connection he
goes connections still you see well this
connection is keeping him from coming
straight in
do you understand and that's why he's
got to go around
doesn't look like it you're actually
doing something that generates something
in him okay so around
okay if I stay here it would not
generate him staying out there at weapon
range he would keep coming in because he
knocked my weapon out and now we're in
grappling ring so to see or ski range
Okay so
what I'm doing instead that's keeping
them out is
now we're in Striking Joe range okay got
it
but
what happens sometimes
when we go to the actual timing is we're
coming in
you see and we came in now and same
thing I would just charge me at that
point
because he's already there
you got to be careful as you go to hit
the hands that you're not
keeping yourself in range
and not creating another opening so as
you're doing the timing do you see
you're not in any different range than
the embryonic level
s nothing changes
I'm not closing and moving up the circle
okay all right let's try it again
let's pay attention to the kiss
so when I move around that the weapon is
oriented towards him weapons oriented
person is a threat there right this
movement could be doubles
and he does a reaction that's when I
come around replace it with the back end
this is very similar showman with the
weapon out on the side
so I don't want to go like this
and then walk
you you get it there's you have that
that initial ski
and then it disappears and you come over
so don't pull it out from here and
you're walking in entirely
like that
you could just even be just a weight
shift in that's enough for their
training purposes in then replace wait
in replace
and replace it
okay let's try it go so when we're
reviewing let's do the test out review
I was trying I I don't have my
lats and shoulders and arms in it I'm
trying to just let my body my body moves
the weapon body is moving the weapon
my body's moving away
that's all I'm doing so same thing on
Showman
I'm not gonna
drive my shoulders and arms just my
body's moving the weapon the weapon is
just falling from what my body is
generating okay got it you're not
otherwise we're gonna break the Joe's so
again emphasize the form as opposed to
the effect on the Joe okay try it again
so let's say I'm doing the show One G
weapon out again wiping out again
okay it's very common in Aikido so I
come around and you have this
back foot ruddering problem okay this is
totally not even external by
biomechanics okay body mechanics
so you gotta watch that rendering
not it
all I did on this cut here is I came
around so there's like so many giggy
because all I did was change the front
half
that's all I did okay you get some
rotation on the front hip but this is
now taken away from my Mass from the
force equation Okay so
here's what I was doing Showman
I'd be here
not here I shouldn't be there
same way just says my hand is changing
no
straight in
straight in okay let's try it again
embryonically he's gonna go Showman
yes exact same okay
so if you're gonna go
whoa again
I'm going to start clearing the line
here okay then I move off the lines
embryonically this is now a training
Vector I move off the line come down the
hill
so one two
three reasons yeah
one
two three and
four
okay embryonically like that again every
dominant plate
what's that look like on that first move
what's it look like a block but that's
just embryonic that's not how it's gonna
be okay it's gonna be another stop hit
in the middle of his striking okay let's
get there though okay so this is another
problematic one in Sancho 2 for you guys
you guys okay so uh go back to the
basics don't hold the end of the weapon
like that always give yourself some
space on the end so you can all you're
always ready to use it it's the same on
the knife you you don't hold the Palm up
okay you got some space there here also
that corner of your leverage weapons uh
they can it that corner can start to
fall from out of your grip and stuff so
you don't want that you always have some
space there okay and then you have third
joke your your neutral position is
always sir Joe third Joe is marked by
your shoulder width you don't want to be
a half jump okay so I'm at third Joe
he's going to come around
right and I will move this left hand
to the third Joe position on the other
side I just have to learn where it is
okay so I don't want to go all the way
to the end
because I won't have much leverage here
so I have to move this hand to what is
going to be the third show
on the other side got it okay so you
just have to start here start there he
goes and you're fine and I will move
this hand over to third Joe to the other
side
see that and then I have an I'll have
enough weapon and enough Leverage
to slap that thing down okay
and so now we'll go out of embryonic and
we'll go through the techniques does
that look right no that's not right so
very dynamic
instant
hand attack and staff very Dynamic but
it's passing through that cross
okay let's go